let's go into the dnc yesterday with uh
not yesterday the last two days
with uh everything that happened with
the speeches that were given i got
notes on every single one of them i
listened to every single one of them
but i think josh i think it's
appropriate we have you
give us an update on what happened on
dnc uh day one as well as dnc day two
well a lot happened fair and balanced my
friend try your best
try your best to be a fair and balanced
uh i would have rather watched
the opening credits on the television at
the marriott hotel
when they welcome you with their
pre-recorded commercials
this by far outside of michelle obama
who i still think is a horrible person
but she delivered a great speech
okay this was the most boring snooze
fest of a has-been's
and idiot former republicans like john
kasich and
cindy mccain and all of these morons it
was
absolutely abysmal and trust me if i
cannot wait for the rnc to take place on
the side of the white house
and we already know trump already is
lining up a fireworks show that is
supposedly going to be grand but what
happened in the dnc well obviously
michelle obama gave
uh gave a pretty pretty tough speech
she was extremely eloquent in her
delivery by far she was the highlight
i almost wonder what it is that they're
setting her up for because if you think
about it she's kind of the first time
uh like even with nancy reagan she did
her
say no to drugs thing but this is the
like michelle's really the first
president's wife that has kind of been
paraded out more like a politician
than a first lady i mean she's and in
her own right she's done a great job
branding herself as an actual influencer
because
she's not an elected official right but
she's actually come up to where
she probably holds as much not not as
but close close to as much credence as
someone like barack obama does
and i would actually say that she's
probably becoming more of a figure than
barack obama
because she's a little bit more
outspoken than him but as far as
just straight oratory and delivery she
did a phenomenal job
but man there is something weird about
this pre-recorded
montage uh that took place at the dnc
now i think
and we're going to get into it aoc
that was weird i got to tell you did you
see that
did you see what aoc said what did you
say okay tell us what she said
very weird she spoke for less than two
minutes by the way she had two minutes
of time that's how much she gave her the
lowest time anybody got was her two
minutes
get her and get her out bro but they
know that they have to
have her because she's the leader of the
young new democrats
so they got to put her up there so she
she gets up she's the
she's the face of the squad right she
gets up
at the dnc which is all about joe biden
which is all about
let's let's get all of the troops behind
biden and let's go for it
and she gets up and gives this long
speech well long two minutes
yeah gives this long two-minute speech
yes it was a very long two minute speech
and this is how she ends
and that is why at the democratic
national convention
i nominate the senator from
massachusetts or
the senator from vermont bernard
are you ready for this sanders she said
that at the end
she nominated by the way can you pull it
up you just actually gotta last 30
seconds
it's a two minute day it's not like it's
just pull
up oh she's done no she's not done she
knows what she's doing bro
she is 100 calculated by the minute 39
seconds
i was off by 20 seconds good evening
bienvenidos
go all the way to the end right when
millions of people in the united states
are looking she's reading deep systemic
solutions
to our crises of mass evictions
unemployment
and lack of health care in el espirito
del pueblo
and out of a love for all people i
hereby second the nomination
of senator bernard sanders of vermont
for president
of the united states of america the dnc
is dead ladies and gentlemen
the dnc is dead oh
she's she's done there it's not in my
opinion bro
i don't think so in fact pat
you're going to get anything done in the
dnc in the democratic party you're going
to need the dnc machine behind
this bro she just spat four years ago
the rnc said they would never select
trump
as their face they were forced to and
the guy had to bow down and he was there
for the celebration people behind him he
had the republicans behind you know how
many followers this girl has on twitter
that ain't [ __ ] man
are you telling yourself you've got
she's got the liberals in new york that
are feeling her
okay but but hey let her run on a
national stage guys
might win her little brooklyn dumbo um
and if you don't know about dumbo that's
uh down under the manhattan bridge
overpass or whatever it is
i'm not calling her a dumbo or those
people at dumbo she might win that
little segment but she's not a national
player
go ahead and disagree go say it now
never underestimate a socialist man so
let me hey let me let me underestimate a
socialist
let me explain to you why why why pat's
right here okay
a lot of people got your vote go ahead a
lot of people are watching
the dnc that takes place at night this
is prime time dnc
convention right a lot of people watch
that that is the equivalent of what i'm
gonna say
your tinder picture is or your grinder
picture
okay everyone's got that one picture
that looks good that that's like
their public-facing picture but if you
really want to get into what the future
of the democratic party is
let's go into what's happening at the
dnc during the daytime
okay this is where they're having the
youth panels and their youth speakers
and all this stuff
there was some stuff that happened with
the youth speakers that to me
was like as as i'm watching this i'm
thinking
holy crap this is the future of the dnc
this is what happened in the pre-evening
dnc convention all right they go to play
for
the national anthem now at night time
they had that little zoom montage of
everybody like singing
and it's very pro-american word united
during the day though
it's an entirely different dnc so when
they get up to do this uh
this particular panel they said now
we're gonna play the national anthem
for those of you at home feel free to
either rise
or kneel okay
this is the dnc their convention
and they're telling people that they
want to come across at nighttime
patriotic
but the youth are saying hey if you want
to kneel
that's just as patriotic then in one of
the speeches
the lady actually rails for like two
minutes three minutes on
why the future of the democratic party
is
fighting in the entire she said the
entire desolation
and deconstruction of capitalism they're
letting their true colors be known and
then
iona presley gets up in the pre-dnc
this is like this is like wake up in the
morning who you really
are dnc this is no makeup dnc
this is not tinder profile picture at
nighttime dnc
this is like the real dnc she gets up
and
praises the protesters and rioters
in portland at night they they want to
seem like they're the unifiers of
america
but during the day they are literally
praising and bringing up the
in fact they even had a preacher on
there i don't know what
let me just look in this camera right
here and say i don't know what in the
hell
kind of preacher is going to speak at
the dnc you
baby murdering abortion pre-flipping
idiot
you're going to hell so they get a
preacher up at the dnc
that tells america of course he comes up
ah
i'm here tonight to tell you that we
have got to open our borders
and jesus said that if you do it unto
the least of these
i'm here tonight to tell you america if
we don't open our borders
for immigrants our nation is going to
hell
and i'm sitting here like man this
starts starting to sound a little bit
like jeremiah wright you know when he
said
god damn the united states of america
dude pat i think this brings up an
interesting point and we go back into
this dnc thing
i think you're right there is a new
democratic party that's that's taken
place and you can obviously see it here
there's a war but i'm i'm actually
telling you the republicans as we saw
here at the dnc the republicans we had
john kasich
we had uh colin powell cindy
mccain all of these republicans that go
up on the dnc platform and say
we endorse joe biden what we have seen
ladies and gentlemen is the death of the
republican party
there is no more republican party now
there is
magga versus everybody trump has done a
phenomenal job in branding
now the maga crowd says oh you're a
republican screw you you're not a
republican we don't claim you we'll
never vote for you you're out of the
like
period it's magga versus everybody and i
think it's going to end up being a
showdown between maga
versus socialism and that's that's
that's what the future of the country is
[Music]